a very warm welcome to those who have
just joined uh the webinar
we are waiting for everyone to join
we've been starting with the webinar in
10 more minutes
and it would be nice if you could
introduce yourself in the chat box
and tell us about your educational
background your research and trust and
your motivation to join the program
we're looking forward to
listening to your deductions thank you
hey
hello everyone uh i would like to
welcome those who have just joined we'll
be starting the session and more three
four minutes we are waiting for others
to join as well
thank you for joining
and you can click on this time to
introduce yourself in the chat box
bye
hello everyone our very warm green plane
good morning
from in whichever part of the world you
are i would like to welcome you all to
today's free webinar on data science for
biomedical research
so with a rapid growth of high
throughput data including omix
technologies gave rise to significant
demand for data science skills and
experience with bioinformatics methods
of analysis
this online training program will cover
the practical and conceptual aspects of
data science including data wrangling
statistical analysis and machine
learning in application of high
throughput biomedical omics data using
big data analysis tools on the tbi info
platform r and python
throughout the course the students will
get an understanding of opportunities
and limitations of machine learning in
the context of basic pre-clinical and
clinical research the training is
designed as a combination of online
resources practical hands-on experience
assignments and live workshops that will
be conducted while soon
and throughout the course we will review
several project examples that
demonstrate the successes and
limitations of conventional machine
learning methods and deep learning using
data from public repositories
let me quickly introduce myself i am
sonalika ray and i'm the omix logic
community manager responsible for the
interaction with thousands of users that
are a part of our bioinformatics
community which is managed by pine
powder so before we get started with
today's webinar i would like to take out
few minutes to introduce our company
we are working with multiple academic
and commercial collaborators to develop
easy-to-use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
the training has been completed by over
24 000 participants from 187 countries
in over 300 workshops and due to this
fast growth our team is working with
local and regional coordinators that are
helping refine the local program
logistics and leverage our online
training resources adapting them to the
needs of students and researchers
this training has been completed by
participants in six different
specialization tracks which include
oncology infectious diseases precision
medicine neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on onyx data analysis
all right so that was about us and now i
would like to highlight some of the
current challenges and limitations and
how we at omics logic help resolve
things with our training and research
solutions
so what are the challenges that the
field of bioinformatics is currently
facing to begin this field is constantly
growing and developing new tech and
software to improve processing time and
power the data sets that are analyzed
are usually very large and take immense
amounts of computing power and memory
that many personal computers do not have
also despite being publicly available
data are also usually complex to access
and coding knowledge is usually required
to do so similarly analysis pipelines
and programs require putting knowledge
that many biologists do not happen in a
university setting students have the
opportunity to learn the background
information of designing and
implementing a bioinformatics project
but do not receive practical hands-on
experience with the full workflow due to
the limitations that i just mentioned
previously
similarly the quality faces challenges
with being able to cover a diverse range
of topics if they are specialized in a
certain area of bioinformatics or if
they are unfamiliar with bioinformatics
in general for example a professor whose
research focuses on oncogene expression
might not know much about metagenomics
of sea water
so what is the learning process
in order to create a clear path of skill
development or mix logic employs the
bloom's taxonomy levels of learning this
approach starts with the basics where
the students recall the facts and
terminology and are able to repeat and
memorize the material with this space
the learning builds to conceptual
knowledge being able to understand
concepts and apply information to new
situations the students will then be
able to analyze data by drawing
connections and evaluate when to use
certain methods this leads them to the
highest level of learning the ability to
design and create original work
so how do omis logic resources help
advance scientomatics teaching comics
logic is a portal for practical and
theoretical learning of bioinformatics
composed of courses designed to take you
through the theoretical knowledge
comics logic takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give students a clear path of the
bloom's taxonomy pyramid
no matter what the user's initial
experience with bioinformatics is
omixlogic is a useful tool for gaining a
baseline knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
sets an introduction to basic coding
languages like r and python are
beginning a data analysis project
the users will be given the directions
to access the tbi info platform for
bioinformatics processing and analysis
of transcriptomics data the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and analysis cloud
infrastructure to run bioinformatics
binding
the different stages of analysis are
performed in different sections of this
multi-omics platform this program comes
with an access to the omixlogic courses
which includes various courses on
bioinformatics precision medicine
methylomics including genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
data science that includes
bioinformatics using art and python and
machine learning for biomedical data
an example projects access of different
fields which you could learn from and
replicate for your research work as well
so first of all let's begin by signing
up on the comics logic learn portal i'll
be shortly taking you to the portal and
give a quick demonstration of how you
can create an account on the portal and
leverage the resources that i just
mentioned
and once you have your account set up
please make sure that you have a
complete profile which includes a
profile image full name with appropriate
capitalization
link to your social media handles which
could be facebook linkedin instagram or
kid or twitter and a brief bio about
yourself that will consist of
educational background and research
interest
the mentors can do your progress under
the activity tab and the courses you are
currently completing will appear under
the courses tab
finally after the completion of your
course the certificates will appear
under the certificate stack
now i'll quickly change my screen
and
open up the onyx logic one portal
those who already have an account on the
portal please put a yes or one maybe in
the chat box and others can take out
this time to create an account for
themselves
today we will be going through some of
the exercises
uh in art on the portal itself and
having an account would help you follow
the mentor's instructions and also
practice it alongside
so please make sure that you have an
active account
i can
few minutes for you to have an account
set up for you and then we may begin
with the webinar
so uh this is a quick demonstration for
all of you click on the login button and
this will give you some options to
either create an account for yourself or
sign in with any one of your social
media accounts i just clicked on my
google account and i would be using one
of the accounts to uh get into my
account
so this is the easiest way how you can
create an account for yourself on the
comic sergeant learn portal it's free of
cost and you can then explore the
various courses and training programs
that you can get enrolled into to
leverage the resources
and
yes i'm awaiting responses in the chat
box actually if you have an account or
if you are creating one and done with it
please put a one so we can proceed ahead
yeah i see
a response thank you
we can wait for a minute or two for the
responses and uh take this time out to
sign up so that we are all set
to practice assignments today
all right thank you for some of the
responses in the chat i hope others are
uh creating an account for themselves as
well and we hope to have this session
interactive today where we could uh
listen from you the
answers to the exercises the mentors
would be going through so please stay
attentive and also put in the replies in
the chat we will be availing them
all right so once you have your account
set up please click on this email
address which says welcome back with
your email address
when you click on it you will be
redirected to the profile section now
this is a portrait of your achievements
that will help the mentor know about
your progress and also
the recruiters look at your achievement
so please make sure that your profile is
completed and you have all the fields
built in appropriately
and this is the way how we can monitor
your progress and then all the courses
that you would be completing as a part
of this program you can look at the
progress or the completion on the
profile tab itself and once it's
completed you can download the
certificate from here
all right so that was about getting
started and having your account on the
portal now we are all set to get started
with today's webinar and i would now
like to pass on the stage to mr india
to give us an introduction to the
program over to you media
hello everyone and uh welcome to this
session
i will briefly introduce some of the
objectives of this training and then i
will pass it on to dr raghav to speak
about
how this will be done and what are some
examples of things that you could do
with this
so the data science program
is designed to introduce statistical
analysis and machine learning
provide you with an understanding of how
data is generated so how you can for
example think about your experiments if
you're going to be using data science to
analyze your own data
or how to evaluate other people's data
and spot trends that might represent
technical versus biological variation
we'll talk about the significance of
data mining and finding patterns that
can lead to interpretation so you can
actually think about patterns that ui
identify complex patterns that are not
simply let's say differentiation between
means of groups but how to find these
complex patterns and incorporate
association
and then finally how to study complex
biological systems using big data and so
when i speak about complex biological
systems
any system in our body for example
whether it is uh you know our nervous
system or you know immune system
these systems are complex because they
represent many different cell types they
represent many different associations
and connections and they are also
dynamic so there's a time course
component in them as well
and so when we look at data how can we
apply data science and machine learning
and statistical analysis to be able to
actually understand these biological
systems that is going to be the major
objective of this program so how are we
going to do this first of all this is
going to help you understand various
types of omics data
and understand how data analysis that
you see in publications for example uh
are actually done and and how they are
representative of both the biology and
the data side of things
uh you'll talk about
uh you'll learn about the significance
of exploratory analysis and actually how
to prepare your data
for let's say classification how to
prepare your data for biological
interpretation
you'll be able to find patterns that are
biologically explainable and importantly
you'll learn how to communicate your
findings to your peers so you will be
able to connect the dots between
data preparation data processing data
analysis and biological significance
and i think the major objective here for
most
of the participants that are joining
today is to really understand well you
know how am i going to get to this
where i am at right so maybe you are
thinking okay these are some nice
objectives but how do i actually know
that i am at the right level that i have
the prerequisites that i'm ready for
something like this
well that's exactly the goal of omics
logic our goal is to actually
be able to show you how anyone whether
you're a high school student an
undergraduate student a postgraduate
student maybe a faculty
and still you can benefit from this
program so i'm going to take a few
slides to speak about some of the
important aspects of data science in
general and then speak about
specifically how you can use the
specific illustrations case studies and
project examples that we will use in the
full program to be able to understand
uh and achieve something with with this
kind of training so um first of all uh
today i'll talk about
some of the specifics for biologists
right we'll talk about data science but
specifically we're talking about data
science for biological data and i'll
talk about some of the challenges and
some of the opportunities for someone
who is coming from a biological
background and i'll try to make sure
that the logic for why you would need to
study these things why you would need to
use these tools how do you actually go
from a to b and what would be the
outcome and so the goal
of this whole training actually is going
to be to be able to
find and understand
what data represents
how to prepare the data for analysis
learn code syntax and be able to
identify
what is the question and how to answer
it and i think to understand why data
science it's important to understand
what data science actually is
and that will help us kind of get back
to that same point in a few slides and
think about whether this is achievable
so data science as you know is the
intersection between data
statistics and some specialization
domain and so when we talk about
statistics typically we're referring to
the balance between signal and noise in
our data sometimes we can for example
do some experiment and maybe every once
in a while we see some interesting
pattern maybe the gene that we are
interested in
sometimes is expressed sometimes is not
expressed
and what we would like to know is
whether
we can generalize our understanding
whether what we see in our experiment
could then be applied to biology in
general and so that's where statistics
can help us it can help us understand
how
random patterns are different from
patterns that are reproducible recurring
and significant and so that is the
difference between signal and noise and
to be able to spot signal and noise we
either need a lot of samples
or we need to know some advanced methods
that can extract those specific signals
and help us identify the ones that are
reliable and the ones that are not
then on the data
we have in general just the problem of
noisy data and structured and
unstructured data the data is just not
ready for the type of analysis that we
would like to do
and this is especially true for
complex data analysis so when we we
think about machine learning we
typically think about
data that has classes
that has many groups those groups are
well defined we don't have any
failed processes because our data misses
some
numbers or something like this
and so that is really the problem with
data and then of course it's not
important just to have some data
it's important to understand that data
and so when we speak about
specialization we can think about our
understanding of that domain in terms of
the terminology in terms of the expected
variability and in terms of anticipated
artifacts that we can try to identify
prevent and avoid
and so that really brings us to a very
similar chart that represents here
bioinformatics so today bioinformatics
is less focused on maybe some niche
applications of algorithms and computer
science and in general is becoming
broader because data science applied to
any kind of biological challenge or
problem or question ends up using that
specialization domain of biology and so
what are some things that we need to
know in biology that are important for
us to be able to work with data well one
of the things that we need to understand
is how this data represents biological
uh for example phenomena how this
experiment
produces data that i know uh operates
with certain elements and i understand
those elements so that specialization
domain is really something that we need
to think about as we approach this topic
of data science in bioinformatics
as you can see bioinformatics and data
science are very similar the difference
between them is that bioinformatics is
very focused on biological problems and
data science is focused on general
application of these tools
and somewhere in the middle
of both of these sits the term machine
learning right so we actually want to
incorporate machine learning because
machine learning when it is properly
applied to the right kind of question to
the right kind of data and is
interpretable
makes it useful for biological and
biomedical discovery and so today we'll
briefly talk about some of these tools
like supervised and unsupervised
learning and speak about some of the
differences between deep learning and
machine learning as well but let's first
turn to data so as you know
biomedical research is a
an engine that keeps on churning out new
data sets all the time so you can see
this graph on the left
you can see that over the 27 years that
ncbi has been around there has been an
exponential growth in
the availability of data that actually
is available for all of us
one of the examples is this current
pandemic that we can see has produced
such a tremendous amount of data that
today when you speak about mutations
variance
sequencing everyone knows these terms
and not just people who specialize in
that domain and that just shows you not
only an example of how data is generated
but also the trajectory how this data
will continue to be generated also in
the future now the problem is that most
of this data that is being studied is
actually unstructured and so if we think
about this process of data being
generated
and then how this data needs to be
organized so that we can start mining it
for patterns
we then understand that the process from
raw data to actual insights and
therefore action
leads through a pipeline of
data scientists right and so as we
become more informed with data science
more skilled in data science methods we
now can participate in translating this
raw data into action and to do that we
need to understand the different types
of data
and we need to be able to identify and
learn how to use
data that is already structured
so what is in plain terms the difference
between structured and unstructured data
well if i take a survey
i can ask you
what is your level of education
and many of you will have different
answers somebody will say
i'm a graduate student someone will say
i am learning biology at university xyz
somebody will say i'm a professor
so how do i analyze such a diverse set
of answers what i ultimately want to do
is categorize everything that i have
into just a few small groups and compare
them between each other similar to what
i see here on the right
and that is really the difference so how
do i go from this unstructured stream of
information being shared in different
formats to ultimately something that is
organized and easily comparable
now this is a simple example but let's
think about biology well in biology a
lot of times we're dealing with high
throughput automated technologies these
are technologies that can produce
images they can produce sequencing data
like genomics
epigenomic peaks that i can study for a
different kind of variation produced by
epigenetic processes or i can analyze
gene expression tables
all of these different types of data
come in an
unstructured format and the first goal
that i have is to actually organize them
into a table into a matrix because a
matrix is something that now i can apply
different types of data
methods data analysis methods too
so all of these types of data imaging
clinical streaming data omix data
chemical data phenotypic data what first
we will need to do is to organize them
as
structured data and once we have a lot
of such data
now we can connect the dots between
patterns and their biological
interpretation and so a major portion of
what we will do on this program is link
all of these steps together so that we
have a coherent plan we know how to
approach these kinds of problems we know
what each data type represents and we
know how to get from raw
to structured to interpretable inputs
uh so
if you could please monitor
the participants in terms of
sound that would be great
so ultimately our goal is in the end to
be able to ask questions
identify data sets and produce answers
that are reliable and can be used for
actionable activities so we'll talk
about examples in basic research
research and biotechnology and
pharmaceutical industry as well as
biomedical applications such as clinical
trials and
precision medicine
ultimately the goal or what you should
expect to have after you complete this
program
is number one
how to find data and understand what it
represents so we'll actually use a few
case studies examples that we will
provide for you
but we will also guide you on how to
find similar data sets on public
repositories such as ncbi uh and others
we'll also understand how to prepare
data for analysis so we'll talk about
how this raw data could be downloaded or
what are some effective tools for you to
be able to use on the cloud so you don't
have to deal with huge amounts of data
that this represents and be able to
process them and prepare them for
analysis
you will also learn code syntax so you
understand not only how to read code but
which part of the code represents what
type of method and how to modify that
code so that you can apply it to a new
data set that you're interested in
as well as statistics and machine
learning fundamentals so that means that
you can understand the principles why
are we looking at p values at r squared
at
area under curve what do these things
actually mean
then you will be able to look at a data
problem and understand what is needed to
solve that problem so framing a problem
correctly is very important because
you'll be able to start asking questions
that could actually be answered with a
process
and then you will be able to navigate
biological or biomedical references to
be able to also interpret and validate
results of the analysis because a lot of
kind of questions to these machine
learning methods is well what does this
method really do how do i interpret this
and how do i know that it's a valid
interpretation
and finally we'll also give you an
opportunity to be able to communicate
and contribute to data science and
machine learning code of others
or communicate your project results to
others as well so really omixlogic
provides you with a complete roadmap to
data science specifically in application
to biomedical research data and we hope
that this kind of training can simplify
the path
in this complex field of biomedical
research from where you are today to
where you ultimately want to be which is
whether you want to advance your career
develop your first research project or
use this kind of methodology in your
current research
with that i would be glad to briefly
mention that all of this content is
supported by an asynchronous library of
materials that you can
refer to during the training and this
material is enriched by case studies in
various domains designed to introduce
the specific terminology specific data
sets examples and case studies that you
can start with so that you can develop
your own independent project
with this kind of data in mind
with that i
am happy to answer any questions that
you might have um and if you do not have
any questions
uh you can also um
mention them in the chat and i will be
monitoring the chat um for
until the end of this session and i'll
be able to answer those as well
so uh
with that i'll pass this on to dr
raghavendran lakshmi narayan nun
to take over
thank you very much
let me find ways to share my screen and
okay great
my video is also working
so i am raghuvindran i will be one of
the mentors for this data science
program and
today actually i want to give you an
introduction to the kind of analysis
that we will be discussing in this
program
yes
so uh this
let me show you or let me share you a
pipeline that we have set up for set up
in the server tbio info platform
pipeline is actually designed to compare
contrast and benchmark
different clustering methods using gene
expression data so to give you a very
short overview about gene expression
data we all know that this data contains
vital information that is required to
understand the processes that takes
place in a biological organism in
relationship to its phenotypical
conditions or characteristics of
environment so to understand and
disappearing these hidden patterns in
this gene expression data will help us
strengthen our understanding of the
complexity that is buried in the
biological networks and
the complexity the general complexity of
the gene expression data aromic data and
the volume of the genes present
increases our challenges of
comprehending interpreting and analyzing
these huge mass or volume of data
so the use of data mining techniques
like clustering is is one of the first
few steps towards addressing these
challenges and we need to do or we need
to perform these analysis methods
to process several
patterns that are buried and interesting
patterns that are underlying in the data
so let's go back to the pipeline and i
want to bring to your notice to the
sequence of analysis that is involved in
this pipeline so we start with the
principal component analysis in our
library and
and then we follow it up and we take the
output of the principal component
analysis and then apply a multitude of
clustering techniques like hierarchical
clustering
like k-means clustering spectral
clustering db scan etc
and we finish the for v and the pipeline
so we do this to compare their are these
clustering methods interpretation of the
patterns within the gene expression data
that was provided as an input so before
running to the output files let me
tell you or briefly show you what the
input looks like so if you check this
input this is an expression data and
this data will look like
something like this as a table
this is a structured data that elia had
introduced you to and this data is
organized in such a way that the samples
are in the columns and the genes are in
the rows usually this data will be of a
huge dimension like
the dimensions of the gene can vary
anywhere between uh tens thousands to
more even more like 27 000
so if you check
this one we have curated this data and
we have around 7000 genes in this data
even this is uh
big data right
so
to understand the patterns of this big
data what we actually do is we perform
principle component analysis before
clustering so what pca does is pca
is actually used to project this data
of
huge dimensions into a lower dimensional
subspace
and then the clustering is applied in
this subspace so using pca before
clustering actually uh logically reduces
the diameter reduces
or decreases the computational cost as
we are actually implementing clustering
on the reduced dimensions of the data
pca will actually provide distribution
of the data points in the transformed
dimensional space but pca itself will
not cluster the data points so to
demonstrate you let's
explore some of the outputs that you
find in the pipeline
once you run such pipeline you will get
some visualization options and if you
take some of the visualization option
i think i have already loaded this
visualization so let's go there
yeah so you can explore the principal
component analysis output of this
pipeline in a 3d interactive plot so
this immediately shows us there is some
really good separation between the
samples of different types and if i can
move this over yeah and we have the
color coded
legend also available
so uh we quickly understand that there
is a variable
or good separation between the samples
or at least between the luminal and
non-nominal type and we can employ
clustering to uh
observe whether these patterns are
actually
in the clustering uh techniques or not
or do we have any do we see any other
surprising information in the clustering
so if you check
another output which is the tabular
output of this principal component
analysis platform then we will
see that
the dimension which is of 7000 genes
that we have inputted had had been
compressed to three here we have given
only three it could be uh depending upon
the setting three five ten or how many
components that you are going to
calculate
right so uh
thus
a decrease or using clustering on this
decreased
dimensional space will actually speed up
your process and also will eliminate the
unwanted noise which could be present
when you are dealing with the high
dimensional data so
to understand
all of this pipeline we will have
several of these examples in the session
or in the in the program but now i want
to point you or focus on the
bottleneck of this pipeline which is the
principal component analysis on our
input data so if you
click on the output files you will get
outputs that are associated with all the
analysis that we have run
we have actually used here included here
and if you include or if you
download this
principle component analysis and
underscore r pack dot zip
and this actually contain
the code that was necessary for
the principal component analysis to
generate this
output
so let's go there let's
take it out
so this pack contains the input file as
we had
downloaded and i showed it to you and it
contains the standard r code with which
we uh with which the server actually ran
this analysis so let's
yeah this is the our code which this
server used to run this principle
component analysis of pipeline but we
have given or we have uh
dissected this r code in a step-by-step
manner in an associated lesson of which
you get a free chance or a chance to
explore only for today so if somebody
can paste
the link let me find the link myself
so this
is a lesson that deals with the
principle component analysis of your
input data and i give you
the link for this lesson
in the chat box
you are free to open this lesson and
explore the codes along with me and you
can we can walk through the different
components of the code and we will have
a
we will have a separate space where we
are going to apply this code and run
this code from the learn omics logic
platform themselves
yes okay so
in this lesson we we start with an
introduction to what principle component
analysis can do and how it is very
useful for us to first explore the data
using principal component analysis
as such and
after you have passed through that we
give some examples of the input methods
or input table then we
we discuss this table now and we will
also discuss this table in greater
detail during the program and in the
learn the code section this lesson is
organized by first giving you an
introduction or a specific aim for what
this lesson is intended to teach you or
explain you and then we straight away
jump into learn the code section
where first you get a demonstration of
how to uh use pca for your data and then
we have a code breakdown so what do we
call as code breakdown we break down the
codes into fundamental components of the
code and explain the relevance of this
code and explain how it is how
different components of the code and the
syntax of the code come together
and
help you perform this analysis for
example we have to load some of the
libraries which will enable you to run
this analysis in for example in rs
environment so
it is usually done by including the
library
function and followed by the name of the
library and then we definitely have to
load our input file and this is
done
by
defining where the file is or defining
the location of the file
using the syntax and
this is the assignment operator in r
which will take the value of whatever is
on this side of the operator and then
assigns to the object that is on the
side of the operator
and then we
load up the table or load up the input
file using a read dot table function and
read.table function takes at least one
parameter and that one parameter has to
be the location from where you can
access the file right this location can
be your local computer or this location
can be
a publicly available uh
link that we usually share with uh
with
with during these uh lessons and we have
to describe how our data looks like
right
at least for for a few of the parameters
we have to describe how our data looks
like if you check our input file
our input file contains
if i can go there
yes our input file contains the first
row which
tells you what each and every column is
supposed to be so or in other words in
programming languages the first row is a
header of the columns right we know that
this column represents the expression
value of the sample that is named by uh
named this code and and so on so forth
and we need to mention that to r so that
the data is actually loaded uh correctly
so that becomes one of the description
of our
input file and we have several other
descriptions like how two columns are
separated that will form the separator
that separates two columns in our data
this separator can be a tab this
separator can be comma or this separator
can be any special character that you
can use like semicolon like pipe
operator and etc
and and you can also mention some
additional parameters like how you want
to treat the characters that is present
in your data table and whether or not
you want to load the first column as a
row name which will be very useful for
further purposes right and then once you
have loaded the table into the object
full underscore table
which in this case
the read dot table function loads this
as a data frame so what is the data
frame you will learn much more about
data frame and etc
in the sessions
so uh in a nutshell data frame is a
collection of
data of different of various types a
matrix or an array is a collection of
data of specific data types but while
data frame can have data of uh different
data types like a character like the
logical logical character like
categorical
character and a numerical character of
course numerical
inputs of course so
in order to run several of these
statistical analysis and several of
these analysis we may need to convert
our data frame into a matrix form so
that
the numbers are interpreted properly so
we do that by converting and the only
those part of the data frame which
contains the numerical information and
we convert that into matrix and we store
that into
a matrix by the name expression
then we have to
apply principal component analysis along
the genes as dimension so if you see or
if you notice our input data our input
data had the
genes across rows so we need to
transpose the table and that's what this
specific
code does
and then we can now our
input file is ready and data file is
ready to be
analyzed for principal component
analysis and we can invoke or we can
call the application we can apply
principal component analysis in r by
calling the function p r com
and again p r comp at its basic level
takes at least one input or one
parameter
that has to be the matrix
that
for which the principal component
analysis has to be calculated and we
mention that matrix and in addition to
that you can mention other options like
how many components you have to you have
to calculate
or you can mention other components like
uh do i how do we have to scale the data
do we have to center the data
etc and
once you run this analysis then you can
store the result of this analysis in
this object pca and there are several
options in r
that will
leverage the different organizations of
information that is present in this pca
object so that we can plot we can
explore and we can understand the
principle component or analyzed
components of our
input data so at the basic level we can
actually plot the principal component
analysis first two components right pc1
and pc2 we can simply plot it and we can
understand that it produces some good uh
separation of samples
but this is just
to see that whether we have any outlier
in our sample or how do we go about
interpreting our data so this is very
basic plot which gives us very little
information like in for for example in
this case we see that there are no
alarming outliers in our data and
there is some sort of grouping that is
observed but without labeling these
groupings or without annotating these
samples we don't know what these where
the samples are what the samples come
from so that is what we can do in the
in the following plots where we explore
different options or
exploring the range of
this data visualization options and
parameters so that you can
label you can color and increase the
amount of information that you can
extract from this principal component
analysis pipeline or an
output
so uh just like using plot we have
another way of interpreting the pca
which takes gigi fortifies
library and auto plot is that function
and that function comes with added
advantage of
taking having some presets that are very
useful to us like it takes the
percentage of variance explained by
principle component 1 and principal
component 2 automatically without the
necessary of explicitly defining there
and it it produces some really nice
appealing graphics
and in addition to that what we can do
we can expand as i mentioned the
to other options or other parameters in
this auto plot function to include the
labels for the sample and we can color
the labels and we can color the uh
mention the size of the labels and that
will add one more layer of
information that we can
that that will help us understand the
pattern now we can see that how
where individual samples are actually
located in our principal component
analysis this is useful very useful if
you have only a handful number of
samples even in this case we have
something around 40 or 52 samples and it
becomes really difficult to read some of
them and to understand what that sample
means or
what this group means or what this
specific
sample mean and where this like this
what are the characteristics or
phenotypical characteristic or different
biological conditions under which the
measurement from these samples are taken
so we can actually uh
annotate them based on the phenotypical
characters and and so that
they separate very well or we can at
least understand uh do they separate
very well according to phenotypical
characters or different uh sample
characteristics that we associate from
the uh for the data etc so before that
we can also enable uh loadings uh
which will tell you what are the
important dimensions or what are the
significant dimensions uh that are that
are
[Music]
that contribute the most to separate the
samples into these multiple groups we
observe that there are viruses there are
some some groups that we can observe in
these samples
and if you enable loading we can see
that there are some specific genes it's
like
this
one six zero one eight zero and uh zero
six five uh
six one eight and uh we can understand
that
these genes are these transcripts are
responsible for
isolating the samples to this group and
while these genes are responsible for
isolating the samples to this group and
and
so hence we can gain more information
not
how or where the samples are grouped but
also what are the most informative genes
in our dimensions or in our input
so we can expand the principal component
analysis not only to two dimension but
also to three dimensions in some of the
cases that will be very helpful like how
you interacted with the interactive 3d
plot
that i just demonstrated you and in
addition to that as i mentioned
when you have annotation available or
when you have the sample characteristics
available for your input table we can
load those sample characteristics also
into a separate object and we can use
those sample characteristics to color
the samples and color their distribution
in the principal component analysis
output so that we can understand whether
the pca's variance explained actually
separates the samples according to the
different characteristics that we
associate the samples with
we can extract these sample
characteristics from biological
condition under which the samples are
measured or different phenotypical
characteristics of the sample as such
for example if it's a gene expression
data from a tumor sample then we can
take whether these samples are from
what subtypes of tumor or whether the
samples are from tumor samples or
adjacent normal samples and any other
layer of molecular characterization or
histological characterization has been
performed on these samples and whether
we can associate that to this sample or
you can explore little bit beyond those
molecular characterization of the
samples to the clinical characteristics
of the sample like
like the demographical distribution like
age group like
ethnicity whether they are actually
represented in the gene expression data
distribution of our
analysis right
so how do we do that so we actually now
again go through some of the important
codes that we already
had some introduction to so we load the
packages some of the uh gg45 is one of
the package that will and
let us use auto plot function that we'll
be discussing so far and
in this read.table function as i had
told you we specify the location of the
sample here and then we specify some of
the characteristics that is associated
with the sample like the separator like
whether or not the first row mentions
the header and then we can add some
associated options which will help us
organize the data
like how characters to be interpreted
and whether or not do we have to check
for duplicate row names and messages
so
if you load this data and then if you
check first few lines of the data we can
quickly find out that
the first column is
okay
the first column will actually give you
uh the annotation of the sample
and we can extract only the numerical
component of the sample by selectively
by selecting those specific numbers of
columns that we want to extract and then
we can apply principal component
analysis only on the numerical component
of this column and if you do not do that
then this analysis is going to throw you
an error that we have a non-numerical
character or non-numerical counterpart
input in your
data and here we enable scaling
to be true and immediately again we can
use some basic functionality like
autoplot to plot it and in the autoplot
function as i was mentioning
in the above section we can
specify or we can actually
include the annotation or sample
characteristics that is associated with
each and every sample
we can color the sample according to
their
annotation that we have included the
input table so in this case uh we are
going to plot the principal component
analysis result using auto plot function
and as
and we are going to
mention where this annotation is coming
from it is coming from the data table
data and
the column that gives you the annotation
is group and when we do that we can
immediately see that the samples of
color and
our analysis of this input data
is reveals that we have a very good
separation of different um
sample types like the normal like
luminal and all the four subtypes of
this tumor they are very well separated
as you can see
and um
and that is very good very nice to know
and we also
uh find out that the principal component
analysis actually covers quite a bit of
a very good range or explains a very
good percentage of variance in the first
two principal component themselves like
this principle component one explains 50
percentage of the variance that
you find in the original data and
together they
explained something around 68 percentage
of them
and in addition to that again we see
that we can actually
label them
and is okay we can actually label them
according to the sample size sample type
and uh
we can also uh
these
okay we can label them according to the
sample types and uh this label has to be
sample types there is some error then i
will check take care of that
so once you learn
about how you can perform different
principle component analysis and
how various different visualization
options will help you understand the
output of this analysis and
you can fine-tune the output or
fine-tune the visualization for your
need for your necessary maybe you need
only up to this point or maybe you need
to
include the sample types or sample
labels
along with this output so you can do
that
with the given options that is available
so once you have learned this code so
the next
area or the next section in this lesson
will help you practice all the codes
that you have learned in this practice
and learn the output section so in here
we give you a
a console which is an r console by
itself and we include the codes that you
have just learnt in the previous
sections and we first give you the codes
as such and explain it to you that you
can simply run this code and
you are expected to understand or you
are expected to see some of the answers
or some of the
plots that is associated with this code
that we have
seen that it can produce in the learn
the code section so i simply run this
code
and see whether it runs or not
yes i see that the output tells the
success in running the code and the
answer is correct and i produce
several plots and i also produce an
output of
my principal component analysis
variance
and
i can open these
files and see
whether
the output that i created
agrees or
goes very well or describes how it is be
described in the
learn the code section because we are
using the same
input data
we can check that yes okay it does very
good so
now you can start exploring different
parts of this code and
start fine tuning and start changing
some of the parts of this code so that
you can
expand your understanding of the code
that you have learned so far and some of
the hints that we have given here for
example if you see uh in this
area where we are calculating the
principal component analysis
we again have not used the option to
scale or to center the data so we can
actually do that and some of the example
codes are given here so you can try
scaling and centering the data you can
now modify this by including scale dot
equals true
and center
equals true and then if i run the code
okay i click i can clear the console and
the outputs by uh clearing it
and then if i
let
it clear
if i run the code okay
okay now i have changed something in the
data so this checks for the
pre-calculated data so by centering and
scaling some of the outputs have
actually changed but
that's okay that's why that's why my
pop-up said success in running the code
which is what my aim is but the answer
is incorrect because this code block is
intended to produce some other answer so
now i can actually
check whether or not
i see a difference
if i perform scaling and centering in my
original data
um yeah in the principal component
analysis if you have saved this one then
you can easily check
and you can again come down
and see
how you can write the output right i
just showed you from the server how you
can access the principal component
analysis that is calculated for your
input file and you can save it as a
table
so you can use the table for further
downstream analysis like clustering and
other methods so this
code block actually tells you how to
save the table right and the necessary
piece of code or a focused piece of code
is actually given here where you can
find out how to write an output from rs
environment into a file
and again we have to tell what to write
or what object to write out and what is
a file name and some associated
characters how this file name has to be
or how this file has to be created by
like do we have to include column names
do we have to include the row names or
how two columns have to be separated
just like how you have described the
data while loading in the data
so let's run this and see
for ourselves
yes in addition to couple of plots i can
also see there's a table that is
produced and you can open this table and
you can download this table save it as
download this table and find out
about this
principle component analysis calculated
for your input file so let's
time consuming let's not do that i will
let you explore that you can download
this table load up in excel and then
explore this table further
and then uh
after that what we have actually done is
now you get a now you got a good hang of
how the
lesson works and how you learnt the code
on how you can
access or how you can use the r console
to run these codes and even modify these
codes to suit your necessary suit your
requirements and now in this section we
have deleted some of the syntaxes to
keep you interesting and then you have
to find out where we have deleted the
syntaxes and complete the code there to
run this code successfully so if you run
it as such it's going to throw you an
error and error running the code and
most of the time like in any programming
language
the error message that r is going to
give you is going to be very difficult
to understand so we clear this and then
we can go through this
code line by line if you had understood
or you can also refer to what we have
done here and what we have given here
and
find where the
necessary
completion is required for this and i
see okay i see that the principal
component analysis function is not given
in um in its full form and i also see
that there is a problem in in plotting
the principal component so it's
completed
pca res
and i can also see that
you have to run it time and again and
and see if this produces any error or if
it's not producing any error now i have
rectified some of the portions and there
are some more portions that i need to
find out where the header is and one of
the areas where the error is it's here
and i have to mention
which
column corresponds to
coloring or annotation in the data
expression table that that is group and
if you can know that if you open it in
in another
file or in another tab you will know
that and let's see what else do we have
and we can actually see here okay in
this plot uh we have to mention and we
have to enable label
and in this plot we can mention we have
to
disable framing
okay once you do that
we can again
try running the code
okay this time i made all the necessary
changes and
i get success in running the code and
the answer is correct and i create a lot
of plots which
is very
what all the plots that we have actually
explored and
that will help us understand the
patterns in this data so
after this after uh
letting you complete the code and we
give you an assignment where again some
of the parts are missing and you can
again uh explain or try uh running this
so i give you this as a challenge so
today you can try completing this one
assignment and let us know by an email
or yeah
by email if you can successfully finish
this
option or not and for those who can who
wants to know more or who wants to
explore little bit further than what we
have learned so far we have more options
where
we have another input table
my computer is frozen
yes we have another option for another
input table which will help you
understand uh
the
power of principal component analysis in
identifying outliers so you can go
beyond the basics here
where
you can you will get a taste of what i
have demonstrated you in the server you
take the output of the principal
component analysis and then apply k
means clustering to this to the table to
identify the different types of clusters
or different number of clusters that
your
principle or your
data
contains or your k-means clustering
identifies in your data table so uh yeah
with that i would uh
happily answer some of the queries that
you have and and hand it over back to
sonalika
thank you so much dr raghav such a
wonderful session if you have any
questions please put them in the chat
box so that dr raghav can answer them
all right i am taking this as
okay we have a question
uh so dr sarah is asking which tool or
software do you use for pca
uh dr draga would you like to expand on
this
yes i mean you can use
r python and those are very popular
methods to calculate pca right but pca
is also calculated in other statistical
softwares like spss and other ones etc
but we would
use r on python because of the
flexibility that it gives us and because
of the visualization option that it
provides right it can
it can tackle or you can use r and
python to
have any sorts of or to analyze any uh
type of data and are not limited uh by
the
framework of uh other statistical
software but
almost all of the basic statistical
analysis softwares will help you
perform principal component analysis
which is one of the basic analysis or
exploratory analysis that you can
perform for your data
all right so
sir i hope that answers your question
and
asking questions yes sir i also got a
direct question from kriti saying where
have you downloaded the data so the link
for the data is given in the associated
resources themselves so in the lesson
that i walked you through so there are
one two or three links for some of the
curated data that we are providing you
uh so that you can understand analysis
on omix data types so that that's where
we got the data and uh
while throughout this program
you will find various uh of such or you
will get your hands on two
variety of such um curated data and also
we will
explain it to you
or we will have uh
sessions that discuss
example projects uh which is based on
publications and their associated data
so you will have variety of ways to
get
different data and understand
yeah different data formats
yes analyzer you have another question
yes emanuel is asking what roles does
data science play in biotechnology uh
can you please explain with a practical
example
okay uh
i think uh ilia actually covered that
part but i will tell you one more time
um
so there is
humongous amount of omics data type that
is being generated and that has been
submitted to the public repositories and
there is a huge mismatch between the
amount of unstructured data and the
structured analyzed data that that one
can that one
observes in
in the public repositories and in
publications associated with that and
etcetera etcetera so this is where data
scientists will come into play right
they can take these unstructured data
find patterns in this data and find uh
patterns that is relevant to answering
some specific biological question or you
can just simply
use these data from a data centric point
of view start exploring the data
understand some basic pattern and then
device hypothesis device a problem and
then keep collecting data and
and explore further so uh that that
biology as such is slowly starting to um
acquire some of the characteristics of
data science because of the volume and
because of the variety and because of
several uh yeah of the data uh that is
generated by next-gen sequencing methods
and
of different molecular characteristics
that one can actually perform from these
biological samples
that will help us understand yeah the
levels from different uh components like
from dna rna proteomics and metabolize
and metagenomics etc so all of these
will require complex
data type or data analytics methods that
that one can easily
employ
uh thank you sir i hope that answers
your question emmanuel
and uh partially is asking what is the
importance of identifying
outliers yes i mean if you do not uh
outlier can actually skew your data uh
most of the time when you are analyzing
the data you will be uh you will be
calculating or you will be estimating
the average mean or median of your data
and presence of outlier can definitely
affect the affect those estimates and
and that is why it is absolutely
necessary to
not include or identify outliers in your
data so that you have a um
you have solid analysis for your data
and
and statistical
relevance can be more meaningful if you
do not have or if you do not include or
players in your data
i hope that that also answers your
question you can you can try it out by
yourself
yeah
you can find the average of one two
three four five six nine eight nine ten
numbers and include one huge outlier
like one thousand and that is not an
average representative of the numerical
data that you have and if you exclude
that average you will find that you
exclude that outlier you find that the
average is much more representative of
the data distribution
right that answers parsley's question
and
one more question uh is it important to
have a knowledge of r and python to get
started with this program or a novice
can get started as well
we will start this program like how i
described that we will start this
program by uh explaining it to you the
logic behind such analysis so you will
start performing these analysis in
toward bioinfor platform
so that you are not hampered by the
necessity to completely understand r and
python score but we
we would recommend you to go to at least
that far where you can
go through these codes and take these
codes and apply your data set data for
your code or some modified data for your
code and get an understanding so
you will you will gain
our health and
a lot of resources for you to do that
also so our basic and idea our basic
aim is to help you understand the logic
behind the problem or logic behind this
analysis method once you have understood
that
using different tool to perform the same
analysis uh
is is is
yes it becomes equivalent right you can
use a server
or you can use r you can use python so
all of these are different ways of
achieving the same analysis method so
the aim is to help you understand the
logic behind these analysis
and also we provide you uh for those who
are tech savvy or who are code savvy we
give you option of exploring the same in
coding and development and you can start
exploring once you have once you have
gained so much confidence in
understanding the logic and you can
slowly start
running couple of lines of codes in r
and python and and
you will find yeah you will find it easy
once you have
gained an understanding of the logic
behind this analysis
thank you so much for answering it in
such a detail and one of the questions
that we usually get is about the
sessions so what would be the session
timing would it be live and what if the
participants are not able to join the
session because of their prior
commitments college classes or their
working
hours so the answer to that is that
we'll be having uh the recordings of the
sessions put on the program page as well
so if you're not able to uh join the
live session you can watch the recording
anytime
i at your own pace and get back to the
mentor on skype group that you would be
having for this program with your
questions and the mentors would be able
to resolve it for you so that way you
stay in touch and make good progress
with the program
and uh now i would like to quickly take
you through the program page of data
science the biomedical research program
when you visit the page let me just
quickly put the link in the chat for you
all
all right so when you're on the page the
first thing that you see is the schedule
so here we have mentioned all the
session details like when would be these
sessions held the dates and the time
would be 10 am cst 8 30 pm ist for the
live session
but yes again we'll be having the
recordings put on the program page as
well so you can watch the recordings at
your own pace the recordings would come
up here once the session is complete
so here we have the session details what
topics will be covered and along with
each and every session you need to go
through some associated online resources
which are lessons from courses on the
onyx logic learn portal and you will get
an access to these forces as a part of
the program itself
and in these courses you have the centex
as mentioned as dr raghav took you
through one of these lessons and then
you have the practice session with
english console where you practice the
code block submit the assignments answer
the quiz questions and complete the
lessons that ways
okay so today was an introduction to the
program on august 19 the second session
would be about machine learning and
statistics and then the first session
we'll be covering the unsupervised and
supervised types of analysis
and in the fourth session on the program
we would uh take a look at different
data visualization techniques
which will have the dimensionality
production techniques and the other
techniques as well
when we highlight more on the
unsupervised learning on clustering this
would be through uh running the
pipelines on the data server as well
and then we will highlight supervised
learning classification
next we will be moving into feature
selection and gene signature
construction i'm not going in much
detail of the topics that will be
covered in this session you have the
link with you and you can anytime
explore all the topics that we will be
covering
the next week go ahead with regression
and generalized linear models and then
network analysis on september 14 and
towards the end of the program we're
talking about uh selecting the machine
learning methods for real world
applications so first you learn and then
you learn how to apply it to the real
world applications and then you have a
session on deep learning it's types and
applications and finally and finally
you'll get a chance to meet the mentor
to uh prepare your research proposal for
working on a research project so once
you have the knowledge of each and every
concept that is mentioned here you can
get started with your own independent
research project that you can present as
a poster in various symposiums or
conferences or even have a publication
out of it
so that would be the last
session where we'll be taking you
through this
and this was about the schedule of the
program
and if you want to enroll for the
program so a little bit more and what
you'll see are three different types of
subscription levels
the first one is 45 days and then you
have a 60 days one and then you have a
90 days of subscription
so the program length is of 45 days
definitely we'll complete the program in
45 days like all the sessions would be
covered till then
and
we have mentioned what all would be
covered and you'll be getting an access
to the educational pipelines for 45 days
if you want to work on a research
proposal and have a poster presentation
as an outcome of
this particular program then definitely
you need
like some good uh days after completion
of the program to put these things up
together and work on your research
project and
then you have the 90 days of
subscription that is for three months
where you will get the research license
where you can explore data from these
big data repositories they download them
and then
work on them on the device info server
and run run the code block as well and
have a full flesh research project ready
for publication
so this is about these three different
levels and it's up to you which level
you would like to pick
and for students we have some
scholarships as well so we will share
the scholarship form with you those who
are interested can reach out to
marketing at the
rickormixlogic.com
and i just put the
yeah thank you so much for putting in
the mail address and those who are in
india can reach out to us directly on
our contact number that's personally
just put up so that you can reach out
and you if you have any queries that you
would
like supposed to address you can mail
her and she will help you enroll in the
program and get started with your
journey in data science for biomedical
research
that was it that i wanted to talk about
and if we have any questions you can put
in the chat box or you can also name
yourself and ask
i'll just give the access
yes now the participants are free to
unmute themselves if you have any